luckily Scot Amos is gonna sort me out
Scott welcome to the stage I got your
name right yet no loose and what are we
gonna talk abou Scott Laura Croft and
the Temple of Osiris are sequel to Lara
Croft in the guardian of light wonderful
I think we have a brand new trailer to
show up as well maybe we can queue that
up in the production booth here we go
trailer time so far the trailer looks a
lot like you yeah I'm sorry really
impressive next-gen graphics so wide so
Scott talked us through and she know
maybe what we should do is just watch
the trailer enjoy the trailer
honey's nothing even living that to like
what what does it eats cup that's the
kept free bar that's a scare of Manas
yes madam ancient Egypt Feeney anything
you wants okay now are you doing these
Guerra but you don't need me your food
for sustenance obviously they're the
first thing that stands out for that
trailer if you played Guardian light is
that it's four player co-op this time so
tell me a bit about that so we looked at
two player right we love that the co-op
experience something for us that was
great on lash in but looking at next-gen
for the kind of fidelity we wanted to
get to and be want to have more friends
joining the adventure and for the first
time ever having Lara Croft and a four
player co-op adventure was a massive
challenge and a massive excitement for
us so as a team we couldn't wait to get
back into this franchise and the fans
have been asking for that sequel for so
long we need to do something special to
do something that helps push the
gameplay and pushes that kind of
next-gen experience for us so we same is
it the gameplay very similar kind of
affair you know combat puzzle solving is
it is it gonna be very similar to you
know the previous game which I've thank
you yeah so certainly it has a lot of
similarities because it's based on that
foundation of what we did there right
two players even looking at the be role
to stuff we have in there the characters
running around solving puzzles together
in combat together but with four players
it gets more complex as far as the types
of puzzles we face the world itself
dynamically changes depending on how
many players you have so you actually
have more complex puzzles or easier
puzzles or more enemies the things scale
appropriately for that but for us if you
want to have those four different
characters kind of split into classes
well you have two Egyptian characters
two Egyptian gods you to play as Isis
and Horus the wife and son of Osiris and
then the two archaeologist characters
Lara and then a new character
we wrote into the fixture named Carter
Bell kind of a bellick versus Indiana
general it's kind of that competitor
slash partner that are now kind of
forced together this blood cute between
these two gods so I'm what are they a
challenge is that I guess above a four
player co-op with the game like this cuz
you know when you've got two players and
you're solving puzzles you can you can
work very close together I feel like
with four it could get quite quit
fronting right you know for people
wanting a different directions I'm
guessing this is all online or is it
there's a no cowboy and online scotch
play on the line yes right and there's
actually a mix of those so you and I can
be on the couch here and two other
friends can be online we can actually
blend together and you
number of online or couchboys how do you
stop it getting like just a bit too
insane with four people on what
screenplay oh it gets insane we embrace
the insanity know you'll see even in
some of the stuff in the trailer that
the mayhem just gets massive with all
these guys all these enemies coming from
the undead world launching various types
of weaponry at you and having your
buddies around to help pick you up once
you get killed or partnering together
this whole relic system this whole rings
and amulets and all the stuff you can do
to tweak out your character to upgrade
your team as well means you can actually
share all these powers together so we
actually embrace the mayhem instead I
mean in Guardian of Light and you had
your two characters and forget the name
of the other guy yeah he was able to
throw spears a cleric who climbed them
so does each card to have their own
unique ability again there we put them
in classes this time you have the two
Egyptians that have more of the magic
side they have a staff of Osiris lets
them have this kind of beam energy they
can use like for classic Egyptian mirror
puzzles we have to reflect the light to
trigger something yeah they also can
create a magic shield around themselves
that can block incoming projectiles or
you can climb on top of that to get to
higher areas where as Lara and Carter
the archaeologists actually have the
grapple which we had back in garden of
light so you can make tight ropes you
can make areas you can grapple to and
climb up onto or pull partners up over
cliffs that they can't get to we've also
added a torch that lets you have flair
on a torch mechanic so you can actually
light up really dark tombs where you're
gonna need the light and for solving
certain puzzles we have to go and light
different things on fire to be able to
get through an area so and because
they're too classy does that mean that
Lara on the other all just chop their
kind of skill set is the same right I'm
so you can choose you like one of the
archaeologists and then you can by
choosing your you know your your bursts
of that but your your abilities are
still the same right you're these four
different abilities that's be quite
could be resolving right right exactly
so we had to just put him into classes
but we do have some nuance differences
like Carter he starts with a very
powerful Magnum pistol but it's a single
shot one of the time whereas laura has
her dual pistols so he doesn't kind of
nuance differences between them but in
the end it's really about getting the
classes and then being able to customize
them with rings with amulets with all
the gear and all the weaponry that you
can pick up as you go through the
adventure so is um is this a going to be
downloaded or is that you gonna announce
all the pricing or date or any that kind
of information yet it's certainly built
in the same spirit of guard
so you can kind of extrapolate that if
you will I think you're about to say we
haven't an Icee yet until now days so
yeah I would love to but right now what
I can tell you is it's coming soon and
okay Xbox one ps4 PC so definitely for
us looking at what Guardian did there's
a lot of learnings from that that we can
apply to this let's ask it must be quite
fun I guess to be able to work in the
kind of the world of the lore of Lara
Croft but it's just such as these games
have the complete like different tone
ramaa from you know like them was their
kind of remake of Lara there which again
I forgot on the nickname of it Tomb
Raider and I'll rise with you yeah yeah
yeah yeah so rise of Tomb Raider which
we got trailer just on the press
conference the other day yes and so yeah
I must I mean is it kind of fun having
like he'll just have fun with the
franchise amazing she's serious you know
absolutely I mean even you know it's all
being built at Crystal right both of
these games are built by Crystal at
Crystal and be able to look at this game
which is that classic arcade dual
pistols the teal top like she's out
there platforming ashing fighting
scarabs the size of a skyscraper and
then we go over to rise the Tomb Raider
and suddenly it's much more serious
gritty that origin tale so it really is
two different franchises that live under
the same lara croft umbrella so they
still are part of that world but it's
kind of that different takes of here's
the four player co-op action arcade
here's the much more serious gritty tone
storytelling game so we saw some as some
classic giant ball moving puzzle solving
fair so yeah just talk us through what
we're seeing in there in the game player
yeah certainly so this is actually one
of the first level of the game actually
in the temple of Osiris Laura has just
discovered it she and Carter have gotten
into it by trying to find the staff of
Osiris they've managed to break
themselves into this curse so now
they're cursed
they free the two gods Isis and Horus so
now they have this four player team if
they the only way for them to kind of
defeat set the bad guy get the curse
lifted it to go up and find all these
pieces of Osiris that have been ripped
asunder spread throughout Egypt so what
we're watching these four guys in some
of that mayhem
they're even fighting this giant
skeleton guys that you're protecting
this particular cave but you get the
sense of all four these guys they're
currently powered up you can see some of
the asymmetry here where Carter can make
a tight rope with his grapple the other
predators can jump and crawl across pit
and then even the friends kind of issue
here if you're playing with people you
know sometimes they're not the nicest
people to play with because you're your
friends right so they like screwing with
you so you'll notice that Carter keeps
dropping some of these guys into the
spike pickle
that little bit of kind of briefing your
partner is it the nature from Guardian
and into temple where we don't want
people to screw each other completely
but we do want people to be able to have
that fun of competing and still
cooperating right you're still on the
same quest you still only get through
the dungeon together you still need each
other to survive the tomb but in this
kind of friendly competition where hey
the certain pieces of loot that only I
can get to then I don't want you to get
there makes me of that whenever like
whenever I play Rayman ours is yeah yeah
alright I slap your buddy in the face we
got to do it right slap them off cliff
man geez you know it's too much fun and
you actually play harsher with your
friends than with people you just find
online like we have open games people
can join your Lobby you can always make
it a private match but it seems like
people who are playing with strangers
are a lot more friendly so can you play
at local and online at the same time
absolutely you can make next wean you
could be saying on that comfortable
couch playing and then you no saben at
the production booth kid absolutely
online and in our very same game yeah we
wanted that mix and match to make it as
easy as possible Guardian had a little
more complexity in going back to menus
where you're going we literally can
pause the game bring it up you can join
in the game right there live and then
you pick one of the other four
characters and off we go
so other than that the ability for an f4
player called what else is you and what
else is next-gen a table to you guys to
do well certainly for us looking at the
next-gen distance fidelity even on the
main menu screen in the characters they
are so much more dense polygon wise the
textures and materials and then
atmospheric and effects look at all the
stuff we have from part of mistletoe
going on it's it's a chaotic mess of
beautiful stuff right seeing explosions
and things tramping around you and we
have a lot more destructibility so you
can see things like these columns you
start smashing around is this giant
homage which one of the gods who chases
you do you see like she and it's a
crocodile picked up the hippopotamus a
little bit of lion in her so it's this
weird mix right out of the satyrs
laughing so having that thing chase you
through every tomb and just smashing the
hell out of the world around you this
kind of destructibility with all the
effects with all the dynamic lighting
and then having four players was just
why we were focusing on next-gen I need
Sam so it is only on next-gen right Xbox
one ps4 and PC
excellent excellent and even things like
this right these authentic cooperative
moments where you need your buddies to
escape but very ending right where you
get down to it and a couple of them
didn't make it and this is the kind of
stuff that happens when you're playing
with your friends and maybe even playing
with strangers can you just respawn did
you have a certain number of lives at a
cost right it's a matter of
you have gemstone she collects that you
use for your economy to buy some of the
loot that you can earn so there's
actually a whole system of wanting to
get gems and also one of the at the high
scores to beat your buddies because you
still want to win even if it's your
friends fantastic
what kind of puzzles are coming expect
to see we've seen some of those I can in
the bold moving ones and you know
working with your your co-op buddy used
to get past spike pits and stuff but
what other tempest what kind of new
puzzle a tremendous number of them way
there's flexibility with a great physics
system that we can do all kinds of crazy
puzzles from simple switch puzzles to
lighting things on fire puzzles to
really dark areas even the boss battles
themselves have kind of puzzle elements
built into them of how you have to go
and defeat those kind of bosses so we've
taken all the stuff but we have the
designers back from Guardian of Light
working on temple of Osiris so they knew
exactly what did and didn't work back
then and then I've been able to expand
that and say okay here's some new stuff
that we can use with those physics balls
and the spheres that we use so here's
some more complex puzzles we can create
so I think fans are gonna be excited and
challenge having a great story campaign
but also these challenged rooms these
challenged tombs off on the side that
are optional Kanto really really hard
bubbles if I speaking of fans if you
guys are watching at home and you have a
burning question to ask Scott then the
best thing to do would be to send me a
tweet to add camphor as Rob let's bring
in that lower third again from here
let's just just drag it drag it from
here with my tweet right here go come on
let's pour it sir I did this and just
magically there it is thank you thank
you 7n yes so tweet at me at count for
help if you have any questions for Scott
we got a couple minutes left or I I
still have one more question for you
Scott okay I'm not done yet it's got a
track it down here okay um where'd it go
I hadn't really had a killer question
well maybe have gone through them all
well tell tell us more about that the
kind of the world then tell us more
about your teams is it is it all gonna
be can as similar scenarios or is there
quite love and environmental flexibility
it's a good question people ask us a lot
about the size of the game yeah like we
have all these linear tombs and Guardian
right it was very much a straightforward
fronted back kind of linear game but in
temple of Osiris we actually have all
these tombs but they're connected from
what we call the overworld so it's a
larger space so we don't what I'm
talking a lot about it right now but we
are saying that there is a space that is
part of you think of ancient Egypt you
have to be outside a little bit and be
able to see the world and how it
connects
so it's not just one to Matt to the
other it is actually series of tombs
that you have to find and kind of unlock
to get to them so we do have a larger
world to explore
as far as gameplay scale wise it's you
know people ask us is it it's the same
length of Guardian of Light
honestly the world is bigger and there's
a lot more stuff to do on the replay
sign we have a whole loot system that's
also a rarity system so you have common
items you have really rare items so you
have to go back and grind through some
of these tombs multiple times go back
and say what's the coolest amulet or a
ring that I can get in this hundreds of
these things to find so be able to get
those characters tweaked and tuned up
perfectly so you have the best team you
can for both combat and defense and
regeneration all of that stuff is up for
grabs as players want to go back and
hunt for all the best loot they can find
fantastic well Scott thank you so much
for joining me absolutely my pleasure
close off with one excuse me very quick
question for Twitter
Johnston I'm gonna assume that is the
the former singer of ac/dc says Hayes
temple of Osiris single player as well
or just multiple absolutely plan your
own yeah so that's a very people have
been confused if you keep saying
multiplayer multiplayer we're so focused
on the four player you can play it any
combination of one two three or four so
if I want to send in my my kind of
matrix ask share on my own and play I
can absolutely I don't need have friends
so this game the game actually will
change for one player or two or three or
four so the puzzles will change the
enemies will change come at the overall
story is the same front to back if you
have more characters than you'll hear
their voices so if Carter is in the game
as one of the characters you actually
hear him talking through the game
chatting with the player but if you
don't have him in there that it's a one
player experience so yeah it's like the
back well Scott thanks again man